how excited are you guys for your
nominations tonight we're very excited
we were still just as excited as we were
last night when we talked to you know is
your chocolate ice here it feels great
to be here all my dessert was amazing
last night I'm definitely feeling it
this morning but no it's it's gonna be a
great day win or lose we're just excited
to be here it's a huge honor who are you
hoping to meet is there anyone that
you're like trying to collab required
you know Drake I know the list goes on
you know but we're just happy to be here
humbled to be here and you never know
what's gonna happen it's gonna be cool
now it's fun just to be here as a fan
even you know so I always bring it with
the fashion I love this so we are gonna
do a little fashion speed round describe
your look in one word Oh tonight Country
Gentlemen watch out a secret about your
outfit I'm all YSL everything even boots
okay I got a secret I got this little
thing that connects to my shirt that
goes kind of in between my crotch it
connects to the back it kind of feels
like a man thong but haha it's like
suspenders it's like reverse suspenders
and it holds my shirt nicely tucked into
my pants all night long so it kind of
feels a little weird but it's you know
worth it it's really interesting I did
it last night I had that last I said I'm
never doing that we're the same one he
was wearing even weirder I had no idea
existed okay
craziest well this leads right into a
craziest or most painful thing you did
to fit into that out hmm that's probably
it the customized upside-down suspender
man thong was probably bought borrowed
stolen explained huh borrowed borrowed
borrowed because I don't like to spend
money on stuff like this
nothing bought is this all bar Oh
nothing's nothing's bought on this one I
don't think you guys got a figure yeah
first thing you're gonna do or eat when
you get out of those monkey suits
considering a cheeseburger I didn't get
it last night so tonight's probably
probably the night we talked last night
about collaborations you guys always
have I feel like a laundry list of dream
collaborations for our social we want to
have you guys make a plea right to
camera pick one artist that you really
want to work with and tell them why they
need to work all right our collaboration
plea is for a good buddy ed sheeran who
we've already worked with we've already
written some great songs together but I
think we should write some more and put
one of those bad boys out let's go Tyler
congratulations are in order you made a
huge announcement this morning thank you
very much yeah we're expecting our
second child so we're uh we're excited
and didn't know when to announce it but
we just figured the bumps starting to
show a little bit through these dresses
so we might as well just get the news
out there so we're excited mama to be
let's get'em come on in to Brittany all
right the ladies we just love them have
to say congratulations - thank you
amazing you so much you know how's Liv
doing adjusting to this new role she's
adjusting we keep kind of telling her
that there's baby right here and social
point and say baby just sweet I don't
know that she quite knows but I guess
she'll find out soon
get there so tell me a secret about your
dress Oh secret we've pinned it in a
hundred different places to make it a
little bit of an illusion to hide my
bump today because we weren't sure if we
would tell people you and we were going
with gold just in case we don't win on
real gramming this can be that this is
the Grammy so we're kind of rockin the
Grammy outfit why did it feel right to
make the announcement today
I don't know we just kind of we just
kind of did it last minute we're like
you know I was let's maybe do something
different we couldn't think of any cool
ideas so we figured why not do something
and try to reveal it on the red carpet
so that's kind of what we did you and I
have the same due date my due date was
August 19th last year I just saw that
how crazy is that well so how was that
due date I I came three days early she's
a little Leo she's a little girl or boy
are you gonna find out we'll find out in
a few days last time you guys had that
whole snafu so are you a little hesitant
this time no cuz we're not we did the
actual legitimate blood test Brittany
you look stunning as well tell me a
little bit about your fashion maybe a
secret about the dress I'm a secret is
there some like tummy tuck in panties
and stuff all going on I didn't even
know could even happen but yeah it's all
about the Spanx I think how excited are
you guys to see them be parents to hope
for a little boy okay that'd be cool
they're obviously amazing parents
already soon and another one should be
easy
[Music]